[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
it is no longer a party it's a socialist
party now
tonight on politics now switching
parties north las vegas mayor john lee
tells us why he has decided to become a
republican
plus you have a trio of candidates that
really bubbled to the surface
it's a year and a half away but the 2022
governor's race is starting to take
shape we speak with las vegas review
journal editor steve sibelius about
sheriff joe lombardo
throwing his hat into the ring and from
stopping federal agents to expanding
voter access
and regulating home births we take you
through the week at the legislature
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
we thank you very much for joining us
here on politics now i'm john langler
clark county sheriff joe lombardo has
confirmed this week
he is considering running for governor
lombardo told the review journal he is
kicking the tires
on a run although sheriff is a
nonpartisan position
lombardo if he does run says he would
run as a republican
sources tell our i-team he is talking
with fellow republicans congressman mark
amaday
former lieutenant governor mark
hutchison about picking
one of those three candidates and then
supporting them we'll get into that a
little bit later on
in our interview with steve sibelius
from the rj north las vegas mayor john
lee announced this week he is switching
parties
he's now a republican i've been thinking
about it for quite a while
as seeing the way the country has been
going watching what's happened in
national news
and also seeing the responses that take
place in
in within our state and when the
socialists took over the democratic
party
it was a sign to me that there is no
more democratic party that i
thought i understood 20-25 years
mayor is a non-partisan office here in
nevada but lee was registered as a
democrat when he served in the
legislature and when he ran for congress
that socialist takeover he's referring
to that is members of the democratic
socialists of america that won
positions and control essentially of the
state democratic party
lee's current term runs out in 2022 but
he did not say if he plans to run for
higher office
i think that sometimes if one person
will stick their head up and say
it's time we can't continue to go down
this path any further
that possibly that changes the decisions
of a lot of other people just to follow
waiting for someone to say which way do
we go i hope a lot of people will pay
attention to this and say
i understand the way to go i would like
people to come with me
because nevada is too dang important for
all of us lee is referring to trying to
get voters to go with him to the
republican party
now we did reach out to the nevada
democrats for a comment on this we did
not get a response
so back to that race for governor it is
starting to shape up for 2022 perhaps
john lee will be involved
it does appear incumbent democrat steve
sisilak
will run again i spoke with las vegas
review journal politics editor steve
sebelius about how those races are
shaping up
now point out though this interview
happened before joe lombardo said
he was considering running you asked
about governor
on the democratic side obviously steve
sislak
is the incumbent and uh he is uh
planning to run for re-election or at
least all indications are at this point
that he's gonna plan to run for
re-election
uh there have been some whispers that
he's he's not going to do it
but i happen to think that if that was
the case he probably would have uh said
so
maybe if uh shortly after the
legislative session concludes he'll say
so
uh if he's not planning to do it but
right now all indications are
that he is going to run so there you
have the the democratic side now on the
republican side
uh there's some there's something
interesting going on that you don't
always see
you have a trio of candidates that
really bubble to the surface
and then those candidates are
representative mark amade of the second
district
lives up in reno the um
the former lieutenant governor mark
hutchison
uh who is also a former state senator
and clark county sheriff joe lombardo
they both live down here in southern
nevada um
and what's what's interesting and and
somewhat unprecedented is that those
three are
talking they're having conversations
behind the scenes
with each other basically on the premise
of look a
a republican primary where we all run
against each other
spend all the money and come out wounded
and poor
is not in the best interest of the party
so we need to agree amongst ourselves
who is the best candidate and then that
person will run
without having to deal with a republican
primary with high
name contenders there's going to be
probably some people who get in
who you've never heard of but just the
top people and so
those three are the names we hear most
often there's some other names besides
those three that you're hearing
might jump in i understand that it's
still a long way away
it is still a long way away and there
are some other names
interestingly enough dean heller has
been mentioned he wanted to run for
governor before but he deferred to adam
laxalt
i think he may regret that decision now
given that laxalt
performed so poorly in the general uh
but
we still assume regardless of that
performance that adam laxalt will
perform well in a republican primary
so he is going to be a formidable
candidate regardless of which race he
chooses right now
looks like he's going to run for senate
if he wants to do that
can a moderate republican someone such
as a
mark hutchinson or or a ben kikefer
win a republican primary what does the
trump base
do in adam laxalt's case we know what
they'll do they'll turn out and vote for
laxalt no question
but a moderate is that person going to
get support
in a republican primary that's an open
question and that could really affect
some of the
of the candidates here on the democratic
side obviously as you mentioned there's
steve sisilak he's the incumbent he is a
democrat
you mentioned he's in all likelihood
gonna run again but is it possible given
the recent
uh changes with the nevada democratic
party that he could be primaried
it it is possible uh i have heard more
than once from
more than one person the name marilyn
kirkpatrick
as a potential candidate for uh for
governor she's done
a really good job as chairwoman of the
clark county commission
and and i think she might have
aspirations
to do that um i think that might
be less likely um uh you you mentioned
the democratic party and whether or not
a progressive
uh candidate a more liberal candidate in
the mold of bernie sanders
uh would would challenge steve cyslek
for for governor
i i tend to think that that is probably
not likely
that of course steve sibelius political
editor at the las vegas review journal a
familiar face here at 8 news now
we have our entire discussion online we
also talk about the race for senate
it's over at 8 news now dot com nevada's
secretary of state's office
reports a slight dip in active voter
registrations from march
there was a decrease of 642 voters
nevada has 1.8 million
active registered voters now every
political party saw a slight decrease in
registration
the only bump in nonpartisan voters that
increased by nearly 54-hundred
now to the legislative session friday
was a key deadline in carson city
bills had to make it out of their first
committee now we're going to go through
a lot of those next week on politics now
but for now
let's look at a few hearings on bills
this week one bill that keeps local law
enforcement from cooperating
with federal immigration officials has
now moved out of committee that happened
this week
this is assembly bill 376. it is
sponsored by democrat assemblywoman
celine
celina torres among other things this
would keep law enforcement from putting
immigration holds on people without a
federal warrant
it would also limit when police could
ask someone their immigration status
nevada's republican party opposes the
measure the republicans say
90 percent of people arrested for being
in the country illegally
had outstanding criminal charges metro
police
suspended their coordination program
with ice back in 2019
democrats in carson city hope a proposal
to expand automatic voter registration
might help clean up the voter rolls
assembly bill 432 would allow more
government agencies to help
county clerks automatically register
voters this would include medicaid
and other state agencies because quite
simply not everybody goes to the dmv
the bill is sponsored by assemblyman
howard watts he says this would help
prevent fraud
first of all i think the rampant voter
fraud is a myth
but this prevents um unintentional
registration of people who might not be
eligible to vote
so the safeguards are in place in this
policy
and what we're doing is is building on
those and expanding those
judges have repeatedly thrown out
allegations of voter fraud in nevada
if passed this measure would cost nevada
several million dollars to
update computer systems for automatic
voter registration
the secretary of state's office says
there are concerns about that
installation
the state's health exchange says it
would cost about 6 million dollars to
put this measure into place
close to 10 million dollars for all of
the state the state agencies combined
lawmakers are also considering whether
there should be licensing and oversight
for midwives and home births here in
nevada
right now only one type of midwife is
regulated those are certified nurse
midwives that are registered nurses
already with the state
however there is no oversight of
traditional midwives and certified
professional midwives and many don't
have medical training
assembly bill 387 is sponsored by
democrat assemblywoman danielle monroe
moreno
it would create oversight of this
practice opponents of the measure say
any regulation would take away a woman's
choice about where she can give birth
and who can care for her
the first hearing was on monday
licensure is a key to providing
safe care for nevadans that is
consistent with the scope of practice
defined by the profession we cannot
support a bill that will decrease the
middle free labor workforce in nevada
negatively impact future workforce
development detract from nevada's
historical support of apprenticeship
trades
there is also a senate bill under
consideration on this
you can check out the i-team's full
reports on the issue at eight newsnow
dot com
coming up next on politics now expanding
voting access or
not coming up we're gonna hear from
democratic senator jackie rosen
and republican leader mitch mcconnell
welcome back to politics now
nye county plans to be the first part of
nevada to lift
a mask mandate commissioners are also
expecting to go to 100 percent capacity
in businesses
so right now the state mass mandate is
still in effect
control of coronavirus plans and
restrictions that gets turned over to
the counties
statewide may 1st so on that day
nyah county plans to make those changes
commissioners voted this week
they on this measure they say the
county's infection rate is between five
and seven percent and the cases have
remained flat
but they're still encouraging people to
wear masks the
state board will review and approve the
reopening plan later this month
the race for clark county commission
district c it is still
surprisingly unsettled at least
according to a republican candidate and
las vegas city councilman stavros
anthony
his lawyers brought a lawsuit over the
election before the state supreme court
oral arguments began this week you'll
remember anthony lost the district c
county commission race in november to
democrat ross miller
clark county commissioners first
suggested they would hold a special
election but then they
backed down from that the courts
expected to take several months before
issuing a ruling
battles over new voting rules in georgia
and other states has put congressional
legislation
at the forefront democrats are pushing
h.r 1 which they've dubbed the for the
people act
democrats say it would expand voter
access president joe biden is pushing
his party to get it to his desk
the i-team's david charns asked nevada
senator jackie rosen if she supports the
bill
before the people act we have you know
legislation here in nevada to expand
voting um we also have legislation that
is likely not going to pass because it
doesn't have the numbers to restrict
voting and then
nationally we have the for the people
act to you know solidify some of
voting rights what's your stance on that
right now my stance is this is that it
is a bedrock of our democracy
that every vote counts that we tell
everyone your voice is your vote
and so i want to be sure that everyone
has
equal access to the ballot box all
across america
this is not a democratic republican
issue this
is an american issue the world is
watching
and so there's been no evidence of voter
fraud we need to be sure
that we have equitable access to the
ballot box
everywhere so everyone who's eligible to
vote
has the right to make their voice heard
and the world is watching how we do that
is there anything in the bill that you
wouldn't support right now or you
i mean i know it's early but is there
something in it that you'd like to see
or you haven't seen
well you know what they're still working
on all the final languages between the
house and the senate version so we'll
we'll see what that actually comes down
to as people begin to discuss it
nevada's other democratic senator
catherine cortez masto
also supports the for the people act
republicans
oppose the bill senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell laid out why on march
25th
it would forcibly rewrite every state's
election laws in ways that
defy common sense and are deeply
unpopular with american voters it would
mandate nearly unrestricted same-day
registration
it would mandate big loopholes that
would render voter id
almost meaningless it would make every
state legalize ballot harvesting where
paid operatives can turn up carrying big
piles of ballots with other people's
names on them
is zero chain of custody
democrats want to hide behind the mantle
of voting rights what they're really
proposing is less security
less integrity and a grab bag of changes
that are deeply
deeply unpopular just look at the other
changes with zero relationship to voting
rights that democrats want to smuggle in
behind that smoke screen this bill would
take the federal election commission
from an evenly split bipartisan panel
to a partisan body so that democrats
could rule unilaterally
so far a vote on h.r 1 has not been
scheduled on capitol hill
coming up next on politics now we're
going to check in with our washington
d.c
bureau president joe biden announces a
set of executive actions
to curb gun violence and bazel john
reporting in washington
we have the latest on the announcement
as the weather warms up more americans
want to travel
and gather but will a vaccine passport
be necessary
i'll have the latest you're watching
politics now
this week president joe biden announced
a set of executive actions to curb gun
violence here in the u.s
washington dc correspondent basil john
reports on this latest announcement
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic
thursday president joe biden issued new
executive actions he says
will improve gun safety we have an
opportunity to fulfill the first
responsibility of government
to keep our people safe president
biden's actions
will create tighter regulations around
guns assembled from kits
and pistols with a stabilizing brace as
well as direct the justice department
to publish red flag legislation that can
be adapted by states
just like with background checks the
vast majority of the americans support
these
extreme risk protection order laws
it's time to put these laws on the books
and protect even more people
but republicans say this is not the
right way for the president to tackle
gun violence
he's not holding people accountable for
their actions
he's holding innocent people accountable
for the actions of people who are
violent pennsylvania republican
congressman fred keller says the
violence doesn't come from the guns
but from bad individuals you're not
going to solve that problem
until you get to the root cause and stop
talking about the instrument somebody
uses
and talk about what causes that behavior
keller says the issue should be left up
to congress
but the president says curbing gun
violence
requires taking action whether congress
acts or not
i'm going to use all the resources at my
disposal as president to keep the
american people safe
reporting in washington i'm basil john
bills with similar regulations are being
considered at the legislative session
here in nevada
assembly bill 286 bans those
home-assembled firearms kits the ghost
guns we just heard about
it's the second most commented bill so
far more than 2800 comments in fact 2400
against it
400 for it nevada also previously passed
a law allowing family members
household members and police to get a
court order seizing someone's gun for up
to a year
countries are beginning to implement
vaccine passports both for their own
citizens
and for tourists from other countries
the question is will america be next
some private industries are already
moving in that direction the travel
industry
supports the idea but governors in some
red states are saying no
most people want to travel and they
don't care if they have to show one more
id it's completely unacceptable for
either the government or the private
sector to impose upon you
the requirement that you show proof of
vaccine
plenty to talk about from washington dc
that's why we have alexander limon there
with
some of the headlines right now let's
start talking with
vaccine passports some areas have
already implemented them new york city
most notably what is the latest guidance
from the byte administration on putting
these in place
well we've heard from the white house a
couple times now on this issue and
they've been pretty consistent and
adamant as well in saying that it will
not be the federal government that
implements any type of mandate requiring
a vaccine passport or requiring
vaccination in general for people
to do different types of public
activities but they also say they do
recognize
like you mentioned that the private
sector maybe even states or cities
may implement some sort of vaccine
requirement or
vaccine passport requirement in order to
allow people to travel or to attend
really big
public events like sporting events and
so because they recognize it's
likely going to happen in one form or
another the white house does say they
will help
to develop a system that they say will
hopefully be
fair and accessible to everyone and also
safe to make sure you know that people's
personal safety information isn't being
jeopardized to hackers
or not at risk to be leaked out to the
public
in some places across the country
they're trying to mandate that you can't
have these vaccine passports what's
happening in some of the states across
the country
well in some states we're seeing
governors sign executive orders or new
laws that say
that any state agencies or tax funded
agencies cannot require
any type of vaccine passport or
vaccination proof
but in one state in florida the governor
there has actually gone a step further
and is requiring
that even private businesses not be
allowed to ask people to require proof
of vaccine
and that's going to be a little tricky
it'll be interesting to see whether or
not governor desantis can move forward
with that
because for example there's a lot of
international travel that happens in and
out of florida
whether it be by air or cruise ships
that go to
places that are now starting to require
that tourists
have vaccine passports places like
iceland and greece for example
and that was alex limon from washington
dc you're watching
politics now
congressional delegation has been in
southern nevada this week pitching the
american rescue plan
on thursday a group of democrats
gathered up in north las vegas at a food
bank there senators jackie rosen
catherine cortez masto
congresswoman susie lee and dina titus
and congressman steven horsford were all
there
taking part in the food bank
more videos are out from the government
investigation into
unidentified flying objects this was
revealed by
our own george knapp this week it shows
a group of flying
pyramids floating above a navy warship
the video clip is part of a briefing
prepared by the pentagon's
u-app task force which is working on a
comprehensive report
for congress about the ufo mystery if
you would like to learn more about this
and the pentagon's task force just head
over to mysterywire.com
you can check out the story there and a
whole lot more about
ufos and flying pyramids thank you very
much for watching politics now this week
you can stay up to date online of course
at 8newsnow.com
we're back with you next saturday with
the latest from carson city and
washington dc
take care
[Music]
you